It's only my love for your father, rest his soul,...
...that stands between you and a life on the street.
I have to make a life for myself.
I'll sell one of my signature dresses.
Soon, everyone will know my name.
To make sure your nuptials are done properly, we shall hold a ball.
You shall find a bride.
Cinderella, you don't need to go to the ball.
Please, stepmother, I spent weeks making this dress.
My future depends on it.
Yes! I am your fabulous godmother.
Do you want to go to that ball,...
...and meet a bunch of rich people who will change your life?
Yes, I was just crying and singing about it like two minutes ago.
Then go you shall!
Oh. Well, look at that. This is different.
Okay, dang, you said you wanted to be a businesswoman.
It's magic time.
Where's my tail?
I can't balance without my tail!
Oh my god. That didn't happen.
It didn't happen.
Hi, would you like to dance?
Right now?
Where did you get that dress?
I designed it.
I pick you to be my princess.
What about my work?
I don't want a life stuck waving from a royal box...
...any more than a life confined to a basement.
Life outside this basement starts right now.